louder with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter and hopper
[Music]
the fan Gavin dot-com what's it all
about
no I want you to remember that no
bastard never beat the SPLC being all
pili Wally and eating jammie Dodgers on
the coach he's succeeded by getting off
his ass while those pili Wally's eat
jelly Dodgers on the coach big man all
this stuff you've heard about the
Southern Poverty Law Center it's a lot
about salute shake Americans fell asleep
our buzzing fee free speech all real
Americans are mad we saying what they
think even when their partner is wrong
when youse were wings when you all
admired the controversial comedians the
belly cordially the outspoken class
clown the old man feed on the road you
wouldn't take any Street League road
bloody nails but even Jack and vector
Americans love free speech and they're
no good 'totally a load of pure Shh
Daphne's taking it away no I would never
say old your wish to manage bum wasn't
new in day that's why Americans are
never lost and never well lose free
speech because the very thought of
having no rights is hateful to Americans
that perverted peer puffers who wrote
that stuff about marwene don't know
anything more about the real free speech
pal then they know about getting their
haul and I've got a strong feeling these
Jesse's haven't he even went about now
if the best spirit and the best
innovators in the world you know by god
I actually play those lazy crybaby
baskets we're going up against by God I
do and well no we're just gonna fight
the SPOC we're gonna sue them and use
their job is to grease the wheels of
freedom what could it be those bastards
one lawsuit at a time no some of you
boys and girls and Z's have ever made up
pronouns you have
user wandering or not I'll check a new
outdoor fire don't worry about that I
can assure you I'll do my bidding the
SPS here near elk are the enemy and I'll
serve out them I'll Kim the class caucus
and have their spin their spawn Dooley's
or lawyers we're gonna grab the SPLC by
the deck am I gonna kick them in the ass
we're gonna kick the hell in them all
the time and we're gonna fight through
them like crap through a goose
it's gonna be a square go and there's
gonna be guys scattered know this one
thing we'll be able to see after let's
fight and you may thank God or me for it
thirty years from the new when you're
sitting on the far side with your grand
wing on your knee and he asks you hear
you what did you do about free speech
you would have to say watch Saturn and
watch it all come crashing down
alright knew your son's about you know
how I feel I may be it mine I'm game and
that's what matters and I will be bloody
proud to lead use people into this legal
Bowl anytime anywhere need Pizza defend
Gavin calm that's all
[Music]
[Music]
that's called the I'm not sick
because I am sick do you have AIDS very
well might I have known we have Alex
Jones on the show today controversial
figure warning goes a pre-tape because I
didn't if my voice would hold up but
milton attended web edition that will be
available excuse me from our club
members and we have quarterblack here
show them your that's absolutely
terrible we have hey in third chair you
know i'm you love them my mood Alma mood
isis isis communications director
communications director extraordinaire
good to see you again Stephen it's
surprising that we have your revisits
yes you know I appreciate yes and we
also have had G Morgan Jr what's one of
the day one of the day is eight years in
the desert Zinfandel about that sounds
anti-semitic I don't know I would send
up your alley that would send you know I
don't do why and what is the wine tastes
like it's illegal I thought it was
there's in the desert it's called eight
years in the desert yes another white
forty but eight years I know work in the
math yeah but the principles are saying
right highlight this week for Democrats
Farrakhan endorsing Omar representative
james Clyburn implying a more had it
worse than your you know average
Holocaust survivor let us know in the
comments below
we're going to get to court now
potential campaign finance violations
and although we actually will have
Cortes on the show Oh what do you what
would you say there Mahmud this week is
the highlight for Democrats Oh anything
with the Ilhan alma mater man yeah
family from another party yeah she come
up for your ranks did you any
relationship with her no I never crossed
paths with her okay but maybe one day
maybe she's already married your brother
it's too late for the news before that
Google you guys read about this Google
attempted to address wage equity good
idly turns out they're paying men way
less than women this comes to me at
times huh
a survey of salary reached the
surprising conclusion men were being
underpaid but the company acknowledged
that the analysis did not address
broader
choose a gender inequity to swiftly
resolve the gap google immediately
executed all men by way of crucifixion
yeah that's until remaining a question
reached for comment commander tell woman
said they could so they actually we
don't hear from them a whole lot that's
a quality crucifixion somebody who's
done it many times you're like wow what
would you say Sinead comprable to Google
look for a guy is it easier to get ahead
oh definitely definitely the guy is
definitely better at getting ahead even
two heads
[Laughter]
listen terrestrial that is not a sexual
reference merely murder but I love the
last part of that the broader issues of
gender and equity I'm like okay so you
guys have been feeding us this gender
pay gap line forever despite facts to
the contrary and you finally do it study
on it you're like oh but there's broader
issues of inequity we have to pivot real
quick yes there are broader issues it's
almost like brown like there's us carry
a lot yeah there's a lot it's scary it's
gonna turn and when it does it's not
gonna be pretty turning to I guess we'll
call this I guess we'll call us next or
a science fiction an X transgender man
now wants to live life as a sexless
alien also he said his nipples removed
we'll get to that in a second this comes
from the mirror what Sharia jerath okay
before I go continuous
who else here when you read this story
read ok sexless alien remove nipples
named jerath knew immediately show of
hands it was named after David Bowie
from labret Lee so jerath named after
David Bowie's character labyrinth says
thank you for clarifying mirror just
wants people to accept who he is and
admit that he would rather be called a
thing or it he's not looking for
full-blown
acceptance like a clown for tolerance
was this said I said it like the clown
yeah pretty much in a spirit of fairness
it's important to acknowledge ok not all
trans aliens are a monolith as seen by
Z's colleagues they're stern rebuke at
today's press conference you know as
president of the space alien [ __ ] of
America and one who's worked tirelessly
for intergalactic zis rights I feel it's
imperative to
the jerath is not representative of our
community you call this a cop talk about
a hatchet job already fixed it
oh and the tree just killed itself so
that was that yeah a lot of developments
can happen on the show and yeah do you
monetize but it's those issues we're not
supposed to talk with the instability
this is a person who cut off their
nipples wants to name themselves after
not even a very good film by the way not
a great film that's a very nice and then
once the rest of us go along with this
delusion look I don't know what you have
to steal to have your nipples cut off
this is your country but I will say this
I tried to during the the clip look this
up turned SafeSearch on if you're
watching out this don't ask me how I
know remind me of the space training who
the space trainee with the power of
filet the power to filet inverted by the
way this completely at the foot of the
DIMMs you guys own this you have a once
it set all the news to LGBT stuff LG I
think initially or LGB whatever it was
Jack Dorsey was on the Joe Rogan show
just really said LGBTQ a twice this is
why you can't enforce the rules because
in a blind spot LGBTQ a a IP and a
silent F I mean you have to don't forget
to spirit yeah II have a question it
sounds like I'm a mood they add into it
yeah yes you guys have been trying to
subtract from it for a long time by
throwing a little buildings I get it
they had to it and the good Isis taketh
away so there's the circle keep
everything also horrible film or Calibri
mmm I didn't a tional use a UK schedule
just stopped LGBT lessons after a Muslim
parents protests this comes from the
Guardian about 600 Muslim children
withdrawn from a school for the day
the school confirmed the lessons would
resume only after a full consultation
with every single parent here's the
story gets a little bit confusing
because both Muslims as you well known
LGBTQA IP and assignment number two are
protected classes on the left so here to
make sense of it all we actually turned
to this week's lotta with Crowder
marginalization rankings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You Steven as you can see the
rankings have seen quite a shake up this
week with marginalized status changing
at a blistering pace as previously
mentioned due to their upset victory at
the Birmingham school we see Muslims
jump over gays faster than I jump up for
seconds at an all-you-can-eat feline
buffet I have explained in the rankings
rumors of a democrat resolution
condemning anti-semitism this week made
it appear that Jews might be rising
themselves good afternoon to Circe were
attacked Nancy Pelosi some Democrats are
now demanding an empty Islamophobia
resolution leaving the current
resolution in doubt so Muslims have
officially regained the number one spots
I'd hate to be a goat in Fallujah
tonight most surprising is the shocking
debut Stephan of the trans galactic
space people I haven't seen anything
this surprising since the look on roly's
face when he caught me with his daughter
that's all for this week Stephen now if
you'll excuse me I have look you resting
in the slow cooker we spared no expense
getting al fun retainer does that
surprise you that the left has embraced
your your people Muslims that's number
one that's why I'm here Steven I want
the embraces you know we want you to see
the softer side of Isis and yeah this is
all good news yeah if you feel the
jihadi softness yes same thing actually
ironically because when I ate shake your
hand I'm effectively squeezing the
Charmin finally it looks like it's
accurate you'll get it Purdue's argument
they say Muslims commit Act created the
modern numerical system okay hold on I'm
not necessarily sure that you're correct
about that also how about just using
paper why white B that's what the hand
it is quite the luxury to things that
you like toilet paper and raisin for
also if you had cotton candy no it's
just yes it is cot cotton-headed candy
so finally it looks like Alexandria
Castillo Cortez might be in hot water a
Federal Election Commission complaint
actually says that her chief of staff
could have funneled nearly 1 million
dollars in donations
this comes we have the over lights been
suggested the congressman in our team
could be facing major fines potentially
even jail time to be fair campaign
finance law complaints can sometimes
just be political of course so he would
actually give her side of the story
everyone be quiet we don't want any with
respect she deserves is congresswoman
Alexandria Acacio car Dez miss Cortez
are you there thank you for being with
us yeah okay there is no violation
Stephen okay
there is like no violation well I said
well I said was welcome to the show
that's that's really but you were
thinking it Stephen you just can't stand
the thought of me allowed max of color
being this powerful is you a man so
you're making things that no I just want
to ask you about the FE C complaint that
actually it seems to say that you the
complaint yes how exactly because I hate
that they're questioning me okay no it's
actually a complaint that's been filed
against your chief oh my gosh Steven
this is so tired
I'm over it I mean first you're gonna
try and call out my suppose that
campaign finance violations then you'll
call me a socialist which I am call me
anti-semitic which won't check out
because a researchable clearly says that
I get bagels from slo-moes in the Bronx
every day I'm over it okay congressmen
are you okay why wouldn't I be okay
don't patronize me Steven don't man
provides me a congressman I think you're
avoiding the question about the FEC
me because I'm a powerful woman okay
admit it you're man talking no no it's
entirely because you're avoiding the
question oh yes he's your man voiding my
question now wait wait what question you
didn't ask a question I asked a question
did you have a question don't you dare
man delegate me okay all right this is
going nowhere congressman Cortez
everybody I prude that's never gonna go
anywhere well it's getting concerned but
know you guys were muted though I
appreciate you playing this hey by the
way this week knows this week the winner
of last week's trivia contest is Sarah
is it Biff bethards
the third sound but now
anyways the twitter handle is Sarabeth
for correctly answering that the the
stars were from Cobra Kai but they
appear in the show you're gonna get a
nice shirt wearing I am so sweaty right
now he really is cold oh my gosh yeah
it's really cloud yeah it's cold and I'm
sweating because I'm very very ill yeah
that's this is not good okay so I
actually do want to get into this Acacio
cortezes it's kind of the this I guess
sort of will called the dark money
scheme why that here's the here's the
context recent complaint to the FEC they
alleged that the the campaign moved
almost a million dollars okay
contributions from a political you know
pack split clashing twenties hey by the
way here's what's important they
established funneling it to private
companies that they also controlled
former FCC Commissioner Brad Smith
actually said that this scheme is open
Cortese up to quote massive reporting
violations probably at least some
illegal contributions violations
exceeding the lawful limits also it
looks like a lot of the money to come to
her boyfriend I know that we can say
this has been going on for a very long
time and you guys feel free to jump in
here at any point you can say there's
been going on in politics for a long
time and you know what you'd be correct
except for the fact that a huge part of
contents in a Pinta Santa Maria Cortez
appeal has been her support sorry I'm
very very sick it's really hard for me
to talk about if he railed against these
exact kind of practices that's what's
important to note here if you don't
believe me here's actually a video I
think it's the most-watched political
video on Twitter you know ever with 40
million views in which she rails which
was a cornerstone of her campaign
against what she called dark money and
politics screaming about how PACs and
politicians can work together to
currently move money for their own gain
this is her this is this is from this is
straight from the googlies mouth and I
want to get away with as much bad things
as possible ideally to enrich myself and
advance my interest will even if that
means putting it putting my interests
ahead of the American people so if I
want to run a campaign that is entirely
funded by corporate political action
committees is that is there anything
that legally prevents me from doing that
you just taking notes
oh yeah let's see I've have some
skeletons in my closet that I need to
cover up so that I can get elected would
you agree the statement disagree
strongly disagree steer clear of that
one she's taking notes when you look
back you thought she was being facetious
she's a girl I'm asking for a friend of
a friend because friend who's best
friends girlfriends sister's boyfriend
knows this guy who saw Bernie Sanders
pass out of 31 flavors last night is
this qualify as legal advice that I can
depend on in the next campaign yes how
would you go about doing so
no it's so it's really interesting that
the reason that this is important is
that there is a lot of reporting that
happens when you have a campaign that
gets money right we have to spend it
they have to report all of that if PACs
have the same kind of issue the
companies are set up so that they can
dodge all of that and they don't have to
say anything about what they do with the
money so it's incredibly important that
and she just said what if you have some
skeletons in your closet that's exactly
why you do what she did because maybe
you do have some skeletons in the mood
oh no I was just expressing my love for
a Oh see she's got some great ideas you
guys should totally enact them living
wage we're gonna do a segment on this
next week mainly because she tweeted me
this week and so we're hoping to have
her on the show yeah talk about systemic
discrimination but you know the whole
living wages she's only paying her top
staffers $80,000 right it's actually
below the cutoff for they would have to
disclose the space would be the blow the
cut-off of transparency yes so
effectively she doesn't have to disclose
people if they're only making $80,000 I
don't know what the cutoff is one
reading six is that what it is 126
does 128 of staff would be making more
and he's the guy who is in a little bit
of hot water right now right and they
don't have to disclose outside sources
of income right as well so it really
it's it's it's brilliant honestly I will
say I have thought that she writers bulb
but this is one of those this is
brilliantly orchestrated could just be
by our campaign manager by the way
speaking of brilliantly orchestrated you
know you've seen the Oscars livestream
now for strikes we fought them hit the
notification bell if you subscribe
because that may not mean a whole lot
and also bookmark this page come back to
it because notifications may not mean a
whole lot in the future flood join my
club bladder pedagogue mutt club and
that's the scribe on iTunes for the
audio
and there are some exclusives on there
all right so here's another point there
think we want to get to ism as far as I
know I don't wanna speak completely in
the affirmative here no attention from
MSNBC CNN the left-wing aisle it's
certainly don't have an impost or snow
remember the one story that I think I
did see if any post was conservatives
are trying to tarnish a OH thieves
that's exactly say it gets turned around
every single time um when the right does
this isn't just a white about ISM but
okayed remember Dinesh D'Souza yeah yeah
a lot of people like all Dinesh D'Souza
violated campaign fight here's what
actually happened he wanted to donate
five more than five thousand dollars to
a campaign okay yeah and it was a friend
of his who's running I believe in
California didn't win so he asked his
wife and two friends to do so on his
behalf and he would pay them back later
we're just talking about three five
thousand dollar checks that's it he's in
prison in a halfway house thank God a
halfway house because he would not fare
well almost a year and fined $30,000
with Cortes we're actually dealing with
close to put at least seven figures yeah
potentially we're not talking about a
one-time offense and giving money to a
friend running for office and even when
we're talking about systemic remember
that word Cortez a systemic problem that
the money was transferred in huge lump
sums to the tune of hundreds of
thousands of dollars for vague services
like strategic consulting as far as
services rendered we literally have no
way of knowing what this money was used
for or who ended up using it again this
is important only because of the whole
we've talked about this before Jack
Dorsey talked about this I think we'll
talk about this with Alex Jones they're
not they're not pushing for transparency
in our in the realm of free speech but
they've tried to transition say we're
the ones pushing for transparency as it
relates to election finance laws they're
not no no and they had to jump through
an exceedingly difficult number of Hoops
to make this happen right so this wasn't
something that they were like oh we're
just gonna set this up like you had to
set up two different companies the big
issue that I think right now is that
it's nobody can really understand there
were two FEC people that were
interviewed to say hey what do you think
of this former FEC people and they're
like they're they're probably in some
trouble here like this is there's
definitely smoke here it's gonna be hard
to prove but you only do this if you're
trying to hide something the explanation
that was given though is so convoluted
they're like I'm a legal expert I don't
know what they just said it's very
difficult to follow so we'll see how
this goes seems like an honest mistake
[Laughter]
cheering may have been an honest mistake
too for the drug game hold on cover for
me out to coffee up out but either way
it's highly highly got the audience
convinced that was a wet boy I have no
idea she you know when she filed to run
I think he might be giving them a little
bit too much credit because when they
filed to run they filed in the wrong
district and then they had to refile to
run in the current district she
represents is it possible that the
people the same people tell us the mood
yeah in the wrong district Bernie and
they talk about tax and they talk about
corruption in politics taking the big
money out of politics I get it that
people are remarkably inconsistent okay
but here's something that really but
we've done a whole I think we've did a
whole segment if you got search our
Channel Citizens United
okay yeah they bring up citizens united
a whole lot you know Bernie's hit and
it's we have to overturn citizens out of
politics in a second hold on one second
here
citizens united people who don't know it
was initially about an anti Clinton film
that the Clinton campaign tried to
suppress okay that's what people don't
understand but citizens united and the
case was about the fact that this media
production kept the company basically
making this anti Hillary Clinton film
documentary had First Amendment
protection even though they were a
company but even though they were
corporation so what it was about the
Clintons trying to suppress an antique
Clinton film and the court said they
have the right to do this under the
guise of the First Amendment now that
being said it did Lee that set a
precedent this is what the case was
about set a precedent that allowed
corporations to funnel money into PACs
that's a little bit of a simplification
absolutely but it's more accurate than
what the left has told you about
citizens united it was just about PACs
going in one it gives super donors over
to the you know over to our reptilian or
boys exactly does that remind you of
something Dinesh D'Souza when he had his
issues was when he released his movie
when he was going so hard after Obama to
try to show America like this is not the
way that we want to go and all the
sudden this random rule that nobody ever
gets in trouble for didn't
O'Donnell do something no people do get
in trouble they don't get put in jail
yeah don't they go in a kind of
punishment right so and what did Rosie
O'Donnell do something way way way way
way WAY worse it's not about the law
it's about the law being applied equally
right and that's I mean it's really
important and especially when you're
talking about government being used as
an arm to prosecute people listen I
don't want Donald Trump prosecuting
people who disagree with you no that's
why any time he gets into expanding
libel laws with the media Kahala saying
I'm really uncomfortable with this I do
think consistency is important and if
you look at the way the laws are applied
there and they haven't been applied
equally certainly he did it don't get me
wrong initially did it's been weaponized
it has been weaponized and I don't think
the court has it as far as I know right
now at the time of this video facing any
any jail time or fines but the hypocrisy
here it's truly breathtaking I don't
even know how to set up this next clip
but she continued just let's watch it
green light for hush money I can do all
sorts of terrible things it's totally
legal right so I use my special interest
dark money fund a campaign to pay off
folks that I need to pay off and get
elected so now I'm elected me I've got
the power to draft lobby and shape the
lottery govern the United States of
America who is describing themselves for
700 mr. Trebek back then pancreatic oh
that's really wrong but I do like the
guy the guys in America and faced with
American institution oh man I just
stepped on my own joke and everyone's
gonna feel bad oh no it's not even
facetious I'm actually just trying to
get Intel see what their chief of staff
and said we write down what we did so
that I can say yes she use a pick by her
standards dark money to get elected and
yes now she is shaping our laws is this
really the kind of person that you want
in power one who can rail against dark
money one second the PAC's is not a new
concept while knowing though that she is
doing exactly
look at that and I know people talk
about Donald Trump lying and I think we
could all agree he's done that in the
past but the difference before his show
is Donald Trump he's right about
something even if he doesn't understand
why he's right yeah you know he might
say don't listen listen you guys screw
up the housing market excuse me okay
excuse me let's no Freddie Fannie Mae
Freddie Mac okay fake news you're wrong
he understands what he's talking but he
is right yeah exactly nobody's got
people that knows doesn't understand
what she's talking about and she's
incredibly incredibly dangerous she has
zero clue that poses problems in our
system of government and I guarantee
that she thinks all of the fans that she
has right now the people that are
following her kind of whatever on social
media are actually there because she has
good ideas we're there because it's a
dumpster fire lady
okay so we're waiting for your game
we're waiting for you to do something
stupid
next you're providing material every
single okay we'll get to that right
before the break before we go to Alex
Jones yeah no but it's fun to watch
Gerald to me it's fun it's fun it's it's
she's angry I like the jacket well if
you want the demise of the United shape
reportedly do I mean let's be honest
okay yeah she looks like she picked that
jacket out of a lineup from the leaving
Neverland cast anyone who watched
leaving Neverland that is very
disturbing it really bothers me about
about Cortez okay the sort of praise you
hear up or even from conservatives as
well you've heard of this about Bernie
at least she's genuine at least Cortez
she really she really actually she's
authentic she she believes that she
claims who cares who cares don't care
Bernie is authentic I don't get it you
know I don't even think that he's
announced anything because he has three
houses I really don't I bring it up
because I think it's hypocritical but I
think he probably believes what he
espouses but it doesn't matter she and
he they're just genuinely selfish
yeah socialism is an inherently selfish
worldview
she acts like taking other people's
money as altruistic right okay me saying
that I don't want to take money I'm mad
I don't have a right to take money from
millionaires or billionaires even though
they make money
more money than me I am NOT amongst them
I'm sure they are shocked to find out
that this program does not place me
amongst their ranks I don't
that's the opposite of them saying that
they want to take your money is wanting
to keep money that you've earned
reasonable wanting to take someone's
money that you haven't selfish and and
they don't even run their campaigns any
differently they redistribute wealth
however they like and I'm just have this
frog in my throat here it is
unbelievable Charlie in the box right no
the boss well the solution is to get rid
of all the billionaires but the
solutions also to take all the
billionaires money so that's it's
difficult you have to do one or the
other I think it really is a selfish
ideologies in in Boerne in Cortez
they're just overgrown selfish children
who've just happened to have gotten
older but she's running her entire
campaign was this robbed you well you
you didn't own that money but I so I
want it I will
I bought it while horsing that's a baby
you got but I don't I don't want it can
I kill it can I tell it can i couch
apparently so she's like a bald eagles
stuck in the oil off with Dawn by your
own admission it says that you're
unwilling to work so and I still want a
monthly paycheck I want it but you said
you're unwilling to work but can I have
more money no that's not how this works
this is what it ultimately comes down to
the progressive worldview and we for
some reason we've we've accepted this
myth or the society at large is accepted
this I don't want to even say this myth
but this false narrative and I know that
sounds so pedestrian and overplay but it
really is a false narrative that it is
somehow compassionate that it is somehow
selfless to spend somebody else's money
no right now if anyone in this room
tried to take someone else's money and
spend it they would be immediately fired
because I'm compassionate and he's a
dick he's done that before multiple
times it's you knew that there was more
money in your check than is usually a
lot of you took it anyway supposed to go
to me did yeah it was fine I said thank
you yeah no no how would I move right
there
absolutely it's the absolute worst thing
to do is to take other people's money it
has had the worst results a word no it
is economically speaking now that yes
speaking
all right okay economically speaking the
worst thing it'll have the worst results
the world has lost countless millions of
people countries ruined and thrown in
the trash bin of history yet these
people try to go back to those policies
and say this is compassionate no it's
not compassionate when millions of your
salesmen each other for food
they tried right we tried right except
for nearly everywhere outside of the
United States and even some tried it to
try to try it then they reversed it then
they went back and it's just it listen
it's just you know congressman Cortes
actually did respond to me on Twitter
regarding actually today about the
systemic discrimination so I asked could
you do me see I'll keep this up here
could you give me any examples of
systemic discrimination you think people
I want you to comment let her know it'd
be respectful because I do think that a
dialog engaging would be productive here
yes but she brought up and she didn't
bring up no she doesn't ring up a source
she goes just last week the Washington
Post reported on a twenty three billion
dollar racial funding gap in K through
12 education and then the other examples
of systemic discrimination she uses mass
incarceration banks targeting black
Americans you can date you can take it
off flavors apparently targeting black
Americans before the housing crisis this
is one I don't want to go through them
right I don't want to parse those right
now because I would like congresswoman
Nina Pinta Santa Maria Cortez to come on
the show we can talk about it but I was
I was surprised that she picked those
three examples I was quite shocked it
was quite shocking yes my cousin
actually is American he's working here
at the bank and he just got the job he's
actually doing the black targeting
training today but the idea of predatory
lending it's like the fact that they
targeted black America so Bank said hey
kid come over here listen I gotta I got
a deal family the racket was is there
some you would would you like some money
that you have no realistic possibility
of paying back here you go I'm gonna
make it rain kid why does that work how
could some be targeting people right
again this comes down to a selfish world
view
you look back at Fannie Mae Freddie Mac
you look at back at the housing bubble
it's okay you're going to have to give
money to people who have no business
being at home now and it
disproportionately affected black people
again this is the law of unintended
consequences here right good intentions
from the left look at what happened with
the housing bubble it's like okay you're
gonna we're just you're gonna have to
lend huh but there's no how about what
any any credit no credit how about what
if the FICO - no FICO score all right
well then how about money done well then
I guess won't you give me a crazy
interest rate like 12%
well how about 10 and then you see
housing bubble and you know who it hurts
the black people who disproportionately
it affects black people who saved who
have business being in those from they
have a right to be in those homes
because then they have money down and
they should actually be taking out that
loan but guess what they can't get in
there because someone else now the
government is determined is a victim of
their own socioeconomic status and the
bank can't foreclose upon them because
they bought three homes that they
couldn't afford again these are the
unintended consequences that nobody
thinks about because it's an inherently
selfish worldview and an inherently
selfish world you just like a
five-year-old who wants more cotton
candy is selfish it's thinks very
short-term all right we have to go Alex
Jones after this and thank you so much
to my mood for being in thank you
what do you need besides a miracle guns
lots of them
[Music]
I'm Trinity no you pan tell us your
Trinity is that all you need
yeah this is the new Walter all steel
frame q5 match red dot ready it is all I
need the all steel Walter q5 match
it has good balance about a five point
six pound trigger pull
try the Walther greetings
America hopper here I just wanted to
tell you that on my eBay profile for
sale right now is a one duggle argentino
puppy named Betty and for the price of
the current offers euro dollars I will
pay shipping
[Music]
[Music]
all right glad to have our next guest
always are you can turn it down there
there Abby always uh well you know he
was just we were just talking during the
break and he was saying you know you can
have me on the show as often as you want
I want you to be on the show you know
I'm from infowars.com creator-owner host
of the Alex Jones Show on Infowars but
making the rounds here recently undone
Joe Rogan mr. Jones how are you sir it
is good to be here with you mr. Crowder
big fan of the broadcast or my kids you
know I'm always well tell you this I'm
always a little worried about you being
in the show because I always feel is I'm
always worried that you'll come on the
show and ask me why I haven't had you on
the show and then we get into a fight
but we've never really had a fight so I
totally get that you're doing a great
job i watch it all the time do you lots
of skits lots of you l'aventure self you
don't have a lot of guests on these days
so I'm just happy to be here and the
great work you're doing over at CR TV
and all the rest of it well thank you
very much I'm happy to have you on we've
kind of changed roles here I notice
you're in a short sleeve or usually you
wear a suit and usually I'm in something
a little shorter sleeve but you just had
a recent surgery that was it your biceps
your elbow or to the shoulder because
that's a huge difference in the surgery
yeah the soldier the shoulder would be
much much worse this is a ruptured by
Sept they just fixed it last week I
shouldn't be out of the cast but it's
it's the the miracles of modern medicine
it is it is I know I know sometimes
people have put you in since you're more
they would say conspiratorial with
anti-vaxxers and I know that you're not
I know you don't shun them the miracles
of Marvel of miracles of modern medicine
pardon me I'm very very sick I mean
there's no way I'm pronouncing that
broad from Twitter's name correctly
today before we get on to the censorship
issue with you and kind of the deep
platforming first what is the feedback
been like after your latest Joe Rogan
appearance because you guys were going
back and forth for a bit a lot of
fighting how did he do bury the hatchet
so quickly well I didn't like the fact
that Jack Dorsey went on there and just
spewed BS a month ago right and the fact
that Joe is like going over Democratic
Party talking points I've known Joe over
20 years we've been pretty good friends
a lot of partying a lot of hanging out
you know get over two decades and so I
got madder and madder and madder that he
says on there I'm not gonna have Alex on
but then he's gonna have my enemies on
so I kind of got upset with him right
but but but then you know once he had me
on we had a great four hour plus podcast
is the biggest podcast he's ever done so
I'm like 20 million views right now 10
million views on YouTube 10 million
views roughly on on iTunes so it's one
of the biggest podcast ever and he's got
nothing but positive feedback 97%
positive feedback conversely the head of
Twitter goes on a month ago he had 80
plus percent negative feedback so as we
were talking before we went live here
Jack and his mother I guess her name is
Vijaya God literally it's her name she
goes on and holds his hand and says
we're not censoring anybody but we did
take Alex Jones off for beating a kid up
and there was no video they didn't name
the kid's name you know you hear about a
murderer an assault to be clear I don't
guess ed you beat up a kid I think they
claim that you posted a video of a kid
being beaten up which I also don't know
to be true but again that would be an
entirely different no I'm pretty sure we
have by the way sir we have you're
absolutely right
Forbes and others said I beat up a kid
and then showed the ABC NBC video of the
10 year old hitting the adult the guy
knocks him down right they just wouldn't
picked that and so then they said I was
taken down for beating up a kid they had
to retract it by the time she said it on
air as a lawyer she said oh well you
know he showed a video of a kid being
beat up it's insane
so how why can't I show a video that
everyone else can shows my point right
know exactly I said it because I'm
pretty sure we have and we probably
provided some kind we show videos almost
on a loop like a morphine drip of Muslim
men beating their beating their wives
and Saudi Arabia all the time just to
keep it at the forefront of people's
mind we usually play the chicken dance
to it so I'll take the flak there we are
far more distasteful than you in the
realm of domestic abuse videos Alex let
me yeah so did you I take it you watched
the recent podcast with Joe and Jack
Dorsey coming back and Tim Poole did you
think that that was kind of a better a
better sequel well it took me from
hating
Oh - wanting to marry him I'm not gay
but you know at the point is they
destroyed they destroyed that lawyer
Vijaya God God
they destroyed Jack I mean it was like a
suicide mission they come on there and
Bs that we're not censoring
conservatives when we've got all their
internal videos from Project Veritas and
all their admissions and the incredible
censorship and they allow anti footed
Docs people but nobody else can and and
so yes this this just shows the
disconnect and how robotic these
corporate heads are was actually
frightening I thought it was actually a
terrifying podcast well I think there
were some good questions some pointed
questions but for me kind of the the
moment where I noticed I don't think
Jack's going to get it I don't think
they can fix this is when he uh narada
CLE used the term LGBTQA about two times
and he didn't realize it you know what
we're not not even the gay in the LGBTQA
are on board with just tacking on every
single letter to that acronym I don't
know that they can fix that blind spot
that was when I was watching it I
thought Joe and Tim did a good job of
holding their feet to the fire but it
felt like a hopeless endeavor I don't
want to be an ALICE but do you do you
feel like that sometimes when you watch
this especially given your situation
yeah it it frightened me because she
said not just that I got in trouble for
selling child endangerment which wasn't
true was the clip was everywhere in the
country I mean I got to it late they
then moved on and said that I said use
battle rifles on the media but they
didn't show it clip they took a 38
minute podcast I did one night but I had
a few beers but none of it had to do
with violence was like we don't want to
be violent you've got to use the
criminal judicial system and antiva says
they're coming to the houses of law
enforcement in Congress to kill them you
better have your battle rifles ready so
they played this word salad game you
like the refrigerator magnets ready
change the words around and she reads
this statement it's literally one word
with quotes around another word and says
that I won't you Joe we had to take him
off he was saying kill the media I would
never do that
hey I don't believe in offensive
violence I'm a libertarian be I'd be
arrested I should be off the air if I
was on air saying get your Bible your
battle rifles ready and kill the media
from the media I know what people
killing me I never said that and I
challenged him I put out a
million-dollar reward when when they had
all these different talk shows I was
covering it that Lester Holt they had
Jack Dorsey on with him he's like you
know it's pretty scary he said use
battle rifles kill the media and he said
we're gonna do all this he was I know
it's scary but we got to keep him on
that was all just a big staged event to
act like right were you know free speech
but there was still plan to get rid of
me and I offered a million dollars I had
lawyers send them letters I called
Twitter and I said I did not say that
and they keep saying so I'm not the
victim I think Twitter is the victim of
their own delusion where they tell
gigantic whopper lies that have no basis
in reality I mean listen steven crowder
if I was gonna accuse you of saying kill
the media with us with battle rifles
would I not show the damn clip it's yeah
I will say this and you and I disagree
on quite a bit but you are pretty good
about that about showing clips
contextually and we do that too I do do
you believe this when you do your
broadcasts I always say listen this is
kind of a standing order have to every
one of my staff don't make an argument
for the left if they can make it for you
always show their clip and provide all
context needed for us to rebut we have
it as a pot and that's what we can hit
with so many copyrights because we'll
just roll Seth Meyers for two minutes
or Samantha bee or Cortes exactly you've
got a show Cortez saying the earth will
be over in 12 years or no one will
believe it
Rendon we play it and we get a copyright
no she's a public figure she said the
world will be over in 12 years I'm going
to play the damn clip because it's
unbelievable yeah have you seen by the
way I know you're not on YouTube now but
it seems as though there might be some
some retroactive changes here after
listening to Dorsey and Vijaya some some
of the road their Redemption right and
you know one thing I know a lot of
people watch us and say well I don't I'm
not in with Alex no I don't agree with
him but here's the thing I understand
where people feel that way but they also
need to look at you as a cautionary tale
of the fact that it can happen to anyone
let's take this example recently where
you just brought up right right now it's
use that because he just run it up the
battle rifles now I wasn't fully aware
of the quote or the clip right because I
didn't show it and I didn't have time to
fully research it I immediately assumed
it was allegorical of taken in context
and I thought man if they can say that
this was one of the retroactive strikes
we found and we know you were deep flat
by everyone in the same weekend so
they're all looking for a reason right
give me a reason I'm gonna go on a
second if they can remove someone for
even just saying hey this is a call to
arms metaphorically to fight back
against the media they can do it to
anyone and I do think people need to
take notice of that regardless of
whether they agree with you or not well
that's it and then people think they
protect themselves when they build a
straw man about me and then attack hit
they go oh if we just throw them under
the bus we'll be safe no you set the
precedent for everybody else so what
they did is they could have gone back
and found some real stuff I set out of
contacts but still some things I said
later that I'm like yeah that shouldn't
have said that it didn't come off as
tongue-in-cheek you know whatever but
but with the case of the items that you
mentioned I would never even
tongue-in-cheek say you're coming over
the hill you know it's the Alamo get
your guns ready cuz they're gonna take
it out of context right so if one thing
the left lying ten years ago yeah it
said stuff like that allegorically that
so the point was I'm like we need to
peacefully to the courts of the criminal
justice system stand up and dance in it
if antiva attacks our homes we need to
not be offensive because like Martin
Luther King said and Gandhi and Jesus we
need to take it on the cheek because
that's how we beat them violence is what
they want the damn 38 minute podcast was
about nonviolent that I said at the
point you'd buy the whole thing I said
at the point of them attacking your
house you got to defend yourself to have
your battle rifles ready of course it
was a debate about how far to go the
point was I did not say go attack the
media that is made up 1 million dollar 1
million dollar prize if you can find me
saying get battle rifles and glare for
the media I'll pay you 1 million dollars
I know I'm not gonna collect that check
just like the people never collected the
check for the United Negro College Fund
when Andrew Breitbart offered it for
anyone who could find footage of them
hurling the n-word at congressman
Clyburn I do think and this is one thing
that the left is admitted now they
didn't use to admit I thought it was
very telling the Jack Dorsey and budget
and
gonna say her name on here sounds like
vagina with Jack Dorsey - okay well good
vagina good that's a cool name like
vagina cuz that's a pretty cool miss
roller making a joke about the name good
if I were her parents I would name her
twin sister penis bad so that they have
to introduce my vagina good penis bad
that's what I would do but I would be a
crazy I came out of the vagina
I love the giantess I didn't the whole
life trying to get my face in vaginas
and D monetize right now immediately do
you monetize thank you Alex wasn't
talking about before I was talking about
something before this and I don't Oh
Jack Dorsey did say yes even you started
it
I hear Gann to start the jokes about her
name since I don't I did it is my fault
I take for raping her name
raping vagina good the name let's please
don't get though are you trying to get
me put in jail like you the social media
D platform field please don't do this my
point is with just cut it out then we
live Jack Jack Dorsey said yeah as it
relates to sort of political pressures
external political pressures I don't
have the exact quote but I remember him
saying yeah the left wants us to do more
the left wants us to censor people more
and the right once less she admitted
that and we've talked about that on the
show for a long time I know you have
that the left demands less transparency
the left demands less truth whereas
conservatives the right libertarians all
of everyone an umbrella demands more
they used to try and deny that it seems
as though now they're not even concerned
with it no I agree so why do you think
they're just openly we're gonna censor
everybody I you know I I um I don't
think that they're openly saying we're
going to sense everybody they tried to
sort of obfuscate and pass it off as
well you know we might get message they
denied it for a while but if you read
like the London Guardian or even Time
magazine or these articles they're like
we want all them off that they mention
urinate they go well we got rid of Jones
we won't get a get rid of Crowder and
although there did they're listing your
name they're saying we want them off air
but Facebook and YouTube are at least
trying to act as though that's not the
case but I know Twitter is pretty open
about the fact that they want to use it
as no you're right the future British
Prime Minister is saying you know he
wants Tommy Robinson taken off YouTube
or he'll use governmental powers to shut
down YouTube so I agree as bad as
Google's been it is not the were so so
guess who gets the brass ring who is the
biggest sensor on internet well you know
that's an interesting question because I
was going to ask you this question is
immediately afterward out right now who
do you who I think is the biggest force
do you mean who do I think has the most
power
google has the most power yes I would
say I think Google then face because
they have both Google and YouTube than
probably Facebook and Twitter's further
on down that list that's why when we've
talked about sort of taking legal action
and we have they're not at the front of
our of our queue because they've pretty
much admitted they want to be a tool for
social change but this is interesting as
you're a libertarian I've talked with
Nigel Farraj about this a few different
guests what do you think the solution is
is a small government libertarian do you
think that the government should step in
and regulate them as public utilities
because as you just talked about right
that's a slippery slope in the UK the
government wants to pressure YouTube to
take Tommy Robinson off but what's the
solution here I'm really glad you raised
that nuanced point mr. Crowder if we
don't regulate the internet with a
necessary evil with a prohibition like
the Second Amendment says you will not
infringe First Amendment says you will
not infringe it's not a government power
taking something away it's it's a
guarantor saying that you have immunity
as a citizen to defend yourself you have
immunity to have free speech this is
sacrosanct this is what we worship this
is who we are this is what makes us who
we are
and so yes I don't like government being
involved I'm a libertarian like you but
then when the EU and the UK and
government says we're gonna use
government power to censor has shut
everybody down who's a nationalist who's
a Briggs etre is a conservative who's
pro-military who's pro-family who's a
capitalist then you've got to have
government come in and say we're
guaranteeing these basic rights like our
current law does on the internet it's
just being ignored and so the internet
needs to go back to where it was where
the internet doesn't censor these
companies don't censor unless
something's violating law clearly and
they get a DMCA takedown order we have a
good orderly system to do this they've
just been ignoring that the last two and
a half years since Hillary Clinton lost
the election
they've panicked they're doing this so
I'm not for regulation but instead when
we stand down it creates a vacuum right
where all these regulators come in we
let the EU and the UK and the Chinese
government's praising us
companies for censoring so that vacuum
because we're like we're conservatives
Harwich foundation these are private
companies loved wherever they want right
well now we just gave in for the vacuum
of all these other very rapacious forces
here's what I've proposed at least as a
step tell me if you agree with this or
not I think that what we need to do is
have some transparency again as we've
talked about conservatives libertarians
we demand transparency I think that
YouTube Facebook Twitter and any other
social media platforms they need to
publicly declare whether they see
themselves as publishers or as open
platforms that they do not censor if
they say hey we're private publishers
like a BuzzFeed like a HuffPo then we
say okay then you're no longer a social
media platform fine let's be honest
about it now we need to see some
transparency if they say you show you've
done your research that's the federal
international law right under the
subsection day of liability protection a
newspaper or TV station doesn't but
because they have third-party posting
they have liability protections not
supposed to be a publisher so the minute
they engage in publisher control they
now lose their immunity right so do you
think that probably the most important
first step would be for them to have to
formally declare whether they are a
neutral platform or publisher because
then we can hold them to their own
standards yes I agree if they won't back
off and stop being authoritarian censors
I'd rather them use the immunity as a
third I mean it's not their fault if I'm
gonna telephone saying something or I'm
on Facebook exactly once it's criminal
they take it down so I'd rather than
revert to what greater minds in the free
market those that built the internet
came up with it works so great instead
of the Chinese model I'd rather than
back off but yes you're right Steven if
they will not stop then we have to strip
them of their immunity okay final
question here I'll go in a different
direction we do have to get going a lot
of talk obviously since you're on Joe
Rogan about the you know you mentioned
the clockwork elves and this was very
entertaining once Eddie Bravo came in
and it seemed as the other words of
miscommunications but it was a lot of
fun to watch here's one thing that I do
want to clarify you talked about these
sort of elven figures let's say it
seemed like you were trying to stress I
noticed this that you weren't talking
about aliens extraterrestrials or
vampires but am I wrong and saying a
more biblically based interpretation of
kind of demonic apparitions
that's what you were trying to
communicate because I did find that
interesting I don't think a lot of
people who aren't familiar with you you
associate you with your more of
faith-based worldview exactly if people
want to find out what I really believe
info wars.com news wars.com
they can hear in this context I've never
seen aliens I bought into UFOs I don't
go to UFO conferences I'm not that guy I
never really covered the lizard people
I've had David Icke on studying
globalist and studying what they're into
they are into the occult just like every
major a ancient religion thought they
were conjuring creatures they were
getting data from beyond the veil and so
when you read the Bible about one-world
government
mark of the beast and and they'll be no
humans conjuring demons and demons will
be settled on the earth and then you
study San Francisco and that in the land
the Liberals they're taking DMT they're
taking ayahuasca and they're having
group events with twenty thirty fifty a
hundred people and by the way Joe Rogan
said this on air we never got there it's
fully but we had an hour and a half
conversation went live he says listen
here thing about clockwork elves you
guys I take the empty all the time he
goes we have group expecially group
experiences we're talking to these
aliens and they look like little elves
and I'm like well listen I'm not gonna
take that because that scares me
okay all I know is the Bible describes
that you can look at black magic books
written a thousand years ago and it
shows the the the magician conjures a
little tangles a little gray alien so
yes the demons that we hear about in
modern culture or the aliens we hear
about modern culture are the demons and
so it fits in perfectly like the Aztecs
would sacrifice thousands of people a
day sometimes because they believed to
open up a portal for gods to tell them
things so it's like chumming the ocean
for sharks to come these lower entities
these demons want blood of children
historically whether they're real or not
I'm saying the elites are obsessed with
it
yes it's far out yes it's crazy but this
is what they believe and they believe
killing innocence or doing horrible
things brings in these entities that
then give them knowledge hey this is a
pre-taped because I'm so sick can you
pause real quick and we'll do this as an
after the bell and upload this is
another segment cuz I'd like to get into
this deeper but we do have to hit the
clock here sure although as long as you
want I don't you know info wars.com
please yes I say infowars.com always
hear that what was the other was a news
Wars calm news Wars calm all right all
these play don't censor news Wars as
much we will be back after this to
closing the show and this
be uploaded at a later date because Alex
and I are gonna go into a little bit of
a rabbit hole here hold on we'll be
right back thank you notes
[Music]
if you don't join my club Maddie will
die where you learn the largest online
news show in the world
Real Talk real facts hosted by Ana
Kasparian and shank week The Young Turks
live on weekdays 6:00 to 8:00 p.m. easy
if you're not tuning in you're missing
out mahmoud al mahmoud here to tell you
about the new club you should totally
join Isis is a great club to do that's
the last time we bring you into the show
I think I want Uncle Sam next a ladder
with CARICOM /w you realize you can get
a steep flip we have Alex Jones on this
show and you're doing that they're going
to say that we're recruiting for Isis
you do not speak for me you'll get the
free vest
you don't talk anymore but I do have
some Walters for you actually before you
leave so I think okay I don't kind of
that calm slash Buckland of course a
wonderful sponsor Walter if you cannot
join at Mudd Club you know we've been
hit with four or five six copyright
strikes this last week and we need to
feed the half-asian Kraken so crank it I
don't know how to pronounce it I'm sick
so my A's sound like ax join my club
[Music]
I am obscenely lightheaded you ever gone
swimming when you have a cold
well you're it's just the worst cuz I
need get that you have all the Stephanie
knows and the cold water rushes up and
you feel hot I just gotta get into a
something cold and then you're
immediately cold afterward Instagram it
is just the worst Alex Jones thank you
so much yeah and again that was a
pre-taped we did that yesterday because
we I wasn't sure if I'd be able to get
through this whole program today we had
a long extended version available
exclusively if you did mug Club members
you made it I'm disgusted with myself
for even doing that next week I don't
know we have we have some great guests
and for the first time I think we really
going to have I believe it's yara from
the change my mind yes this week she was
tweeting us and has been actually very
respectful and I'm hoping that we'll
have her on the show and it'll it'll be
an interesting look back because usually
people don't want to come in the show
afterward never um let alone someone who
was very open about the fact that she'd
had an abortion herself uh listen I
obviously here's one thing I think is
important as it relates to that if you
watch that right there I couldn't have
been more straightforward about my point
of view she has had an abortion she is
pro-choice I didn't say well let's just
find common ground I said no I think you
I think you ended a life I think you
killed somebody and let me tell you what
it is that you ended and we still left
it after that able to to at least part
amicably as a mechanic ibly as you can
so the point is you don't necessarily
have to find common ground under a lie
to be civil and you don't have to
necessarily be simple to find common
ground under under a lie and the other
guys have a life so I got I just
reversed it there I noticed Cortes does
that a lot refuses to think and this is
not necessarily mean that and that does
not necessarily mean it was like it's
obviously we would equate that it would
go in Reverse
sequencing okay all right I won't say
you cover for me there Garrett talk
about something quarterblack something
what's up how's it going DMX black
people okay that's enough this is why
people don't believe that you are any
parts black I know I told you that was a
point one percent sub yeah you're part
of my brother and I think sub-saharan
Africa
it's very broad so it might not mean but
I'm technically more african-american
than a lot of uh a lot of not a strong
reckons you don't look black at all I
know it really is concerning it's all
below the TriCaster because I don't know
how to I don't I feel like I'm pretty
good at filing people according to you
know race gender I'm pretty good at
identity politics and I can't do that
with you
you made it exceedingly difficult um
here's something I wanted to talk with
you guys about let me talk let's talk
about toxic masculinity I think this is
something that's that's been tossed
around quite a bit in Cortes has talked
about this so it seems fitting um I was
at the vet this week and I'm hoping this
is one thing the vet stuff always I
think Joe Rogan and Kevin Smith were
talking with us the dog stuff always
gets me so I'm not going to be too
emotional I was at the vet this week
everything's kind of okay but it's been
rough with the chemo treatment again I
appreciate the the kind words of support
but I was there at this emergency vet on
Saturday and I was waiting there in the
waiting room there was this 15 year old
girl who was crying and it's one of
those things I will I will genuinely
never forget this girl's face I actually
I feel things really deeply but I'm
socially very awkward people who
probably met me sometimes are surprised
I can we do a change my mind over the
show's like be a little bit more
outgoing whereas my dad was with me and
he knows the right thing to say this
this girl was crying she was very upset
and I said hey you know what's what's
going on I should I had to Brett brought
in my 14 year old dog and she had a
seizure and she was she was crying she
couldn't even just tears streaming down
her face
you know that's that's kind of tough and
talked about we were kind of going
through with with with hopper and the
cancer treatment and I didn't know what
to say I kind of just just fizzles out
and my dad saved it and said like hey do
you want do you want some water he took
some water from the fridge there and say
hey I'm buying because those free water
and she kind of laughed she was wearing
a sweater that said Canada on it I think
one of those roots sweaters as a company
and so we asked her she was from Canada
she was from upstate New York and she
forgot about it for a little she stopped
crying for a little bit she was very
awkward this girl - frizzy hair probably
someone who was very very close with her
doc probably the kind of person who
maybe had a deeper connection with her
dog than most people I know I had deeper
connections with animals as a kid
sometimes and they both people because I
didn't I didn't know how to relate to
them um and so I'm trying to find a way
to get into this again I'm trying to
keep my emotions in check when we were
leaving we were okay and as I was to
kind of give an idea what this looks
like I'm trying to see if you can see
scope there's a wall divided and there's
a glass door and so there's a little bit
of a cutout where you know you pay for
your you pay for whatever services
rendered and I can see her on the other
side of this wall through a glass door
the 15 year old girl at this point she
was she was sobbing but after we spoke
with her she was seemed a little bit
better she was looking things up on her
phone a little more talkative in the
waiting room and I sent my dad out with
the crate to our car we pulled the car
around and I saw her mom and there was
no dad there so I can see both sides of
this dividing wall and I saw her mom
talking to the vet and I overheard her
saying how does this work was a 14 15
year-old girl does she you know holder
in the vet said well you know it depends
if you think she's most comfortable
doing that and it's one of those things
where I'm in this position where I can
see effectively that this girl's whole
world is about to become unglued and I
didn't sleep at all that night I all I
could see was her face all night long it
was unbelievably hard and I gathered
myself I walked through the the glass
door when another said the wall said hey
really love your sweater you know God
bless hope hope you had a good night you
know thank you you know and she was she
was smiling I'm a I can't member I made
some kind of a joke and walked out
that's what toxic masculinity is and let
me explain what that means we don't show
our emotions all the time we're all
constantly accused of you're not showing
your emotions because of a toxic ly
masculine culture it's not because we're
afraid of being teased
or because we're afraid of feeling in
that instance I walked out to my car by
the with my dad and I cried I was it was
absolutely heartbreaking but I in that
moment that wasn't going to help her
that's toxic masculinity why did I go
out there and even though it's just a
laugh for 20 seconds before I know she's
gonna have to hold her 14 year old dog
before they put it down why would it
matter why would I go out there and try
to be strong I know it sounds silly for
this fifteen-year-old girl because it's
even for 15 seconds I can protect a girl
like that from from pain and it's the
same thing with our family members with
our wives with their daughters with
their sisters this is why men act the
way that we do it's because we love you
it's because we want to protect you we
hate to see people in pain we hate to
see the people that we love and pain
that's toxic masculinity now say this I
just I wanted to give this girl a hug
and I know I know I can't because you
know of course it would be inappropriate
but um I felt so bad for and there was
no dad present doesn't mean that there
wasn't a dad doesn't that she doesn't
have a dad but it was that much more
heartbreaking again it's this carnal
this primal reactions visceral reaction
that a man will have if there is a woman
who is vulnerable who is exposed and
there is no man there to help her that's
toxic masculinity you might say up the
damsel in distress syndrome fine okay
I'm okay with it it's in our nature to
protect and to provide just as it's in
your nature women to nurture care for
okay we want to prevent pain for you at
all costs and by the way this is I
understand this ironically sometimes
that leads to us causing pain but we get
so stressed out over trying to provide
to protect whether it's work whether
it's trying to be strong emotionally
that we end up lashing out at those who
we live to provide for who we live to
protect just like women ironically end
up suffocating the people they love
sometimes or spoiling them with with
children it's in our nature
and it needs to be rattled that's toxic
masculinity but I don't think that it's
a nature that should be condemned just
because it's a part of our genetic
makeup it would be emotionally selfish
it'll be incredibly emotionally selfish
when I came back home that night too I
came back to my wife brought the
and she was obviously very where
everything was was fine but she was
obviously very worried and I made sure
that when I came in kind I had an even
even-keeled temper explained what went
what happened was we were gonna have to
give the dog antibiotics and once she
was settled about 30 minutes after that
she asked me said what what what's wrong
what's what's bothering you and that's
when I told her what I had experienced
with the 15 year old girl that they were
gonna put the dog down and at that point
in time because I made sure that my wife
was taken care of before myself that's
toxic masculinity by the way and that's
a biblical notion the idea of a steaming
others first of treating your wives and
your women is the best among you by the
way that wasn't an ideal when we talked
about where do we get morals from the
idea of mercy what it wasn't really
considered a virtue in a lot of
societies until modern Christendom the
idea of treating your wives as the best
among the idea of treating your wives
with love and I get it they're gonna say
well what about submit to your husband's
okay it talks about men loving your
wife's that was actually kind of unique
when Christ came around this is just me
talking about my worldview once I had
made sure that my wife was taking care
of that I had called any any fears or
anxieties she had I told her about what
happened and at that point guess what it
was fine for me to be vulnerable with my
wife it was fine for me to shed a tear
and explain something that was deeply
impactful and hurtful and my wife would
never condemn me for it and that's
because we have an open complementary
relationship where we understand each
other's needs and do our best to meet
them as members of the opposite sex
that's toxic masculinity this idea that
men just by the way the idea that
expressing Jordan Peterson is talking
about this just expressing emotions is
somehow inherently helpful it's not true
maybe there's examples right there you
know how I felt when I saw that
fifteen-year-old girl I wanted to cry I
felt terrible I wanted to I wanted to go
into hysterics oh you don't think men
feel that of course would it help her no
it would be selfish when I came home it
was late I was tired I felt this cold
coming down or flu whatever the hell it
is Ebola czar Ebola SARS witnesses are
SARS what is it we had Zika Zika was a
thing swine sexy flu you don't think I
would love to come in here oh my gosh
you wouldn't believe the night I had but
that would be emotionally selfish and so
I ensured that I came in it's okay
sweetheart
how are you let me explain this to you
everything's okay I love you are you
secure all right here's an emotional
need that I have right now when she
asked there's an appropriate time to
express emotion and it's not becoming of
a young man to do that there's nothing
wrong with men crying okay there's
something wrong with telling boys and
telling young men that they should cry
for the sake of crying or that it's
inherently a virtue to cry it's not it's
inherently a good thing to bridle your
emotions to moderate your own instincts
instead of just acting on them and I
would say some inherently good thing to
teach young men to be vulnerable with
the people they trust and they love like
their wives like their families that's
toxic masculinity there's this idea that
people talk about quite a bit as though
men either have to live into this
archetype of big dumb jock or the
sensitive artistic type who cries you
realize it's a very new thing look at
the readings of Teddy Roosevelt or even
Abraham Lincoln these were people who
were artistically for people who often
were musically inclined people who would
who would paint people who would write
poetry and then they were incredibly
intelligent and physically robust you
were not complete you were not
considered a complete man unless all of
these facets made up your masculinity
that's toxic masculinity it broke apart
really with modern progressive feminism
I hate to beat a dead horse here that's
where we really separated people with a
sexual revolution and honestly it just
made it easier for scumbags to get laid
let's be honest that one's not working
out really well for women the original
term I've talked about this before I'll
leave you with this was you've heard
this you've heard its expression jack of
all trades master of none it was
originally jack of all trades master of
one meaning you were expected to be a
jack of all trades adequate passable in
all facets of life and to be a master of
one domain that's what would make a
truly great person a truly great artist
truly great at anything but that what
makes a truly great man as well that's
when we talk about toxic masculinity and
we throw the baby out with the bathwater
we're throwing out everything is created
modern medicine this Western
civilization that has served protected
and provided for women throughout
centuries men want to do that that's
toxic masculinity we want to provide
free we want to protect you that's toxic
masculinity and sometimes it comes with
some [ __ ] that you don't want that's
what happens but we condemn and you take
this is what worries me too is this
generation of boys that we have now
going out there but you know you've
talked we've talked about in cells
that's a pretty small microcosm of it
but imagine an entire generation now
really we're going on two generations of
boys who've been told that all of their
instincts all their hardwiring is wrong
and toxic they're going to be afraid to
be who they are we can't how do you how
do you juxtapose that where you say hey
yeah top masculine it's toxic
masculinity this idea that you don't
want to cry this idea that you want to
be tough this idea that you want to be
athletic this idea that you want to be
great this ideally you want to be
competitive that's toxic don't don't
engage any of those instincts that you
have by the way keep it real
here's know what kind of a conflicted
message that is to send young men and a
moment of theirs and women watch and
it's particularly some some young
feminist women who maybe haven't
appeared behind the curtain who maybe
haven't understood what it is it makes
young men tick we love we care and we
are just as emotional and we don't act
on it because we love that's toxic
masculinity I don't have much else to
say about I'll see you next week
[Music]